a tiny dot moving at nearly eight
kilometers a second this asteroid won't
hit Earth but it will come really close
asteroid 2023 dz2 was discovered in
February by astronomers in the Canary
Islands in Spain it's 50 to 100 meters
across big enough to cause significant
damage to a city and bigger than the
meteor that broke apart in the Skies
over Russia in 2013. the next two nights
when we could recover and then follow up
these objects an orbit came up and we
did realize that it's something serious
if that object would have come 19 hours
later then probably in three years from
now we would really had an impact but
thanks to the new obsaving and so uh
some so-called pre-covery data by two
American surveys now it's eliminated
from the list dz2 is one of thousands of
rocks in the inch International
astronomical unions catalog of minor
planets you can see it here it's orbit
intersecting with Earth's right there
now that means it also joins NASA's
Sentry program which is an automated
system that keeps an eye on All the
known objects in orbit over the next
hundred years dz2 is not a threat and in
fact none of the objects in this catalog
are at the moment there are no known
asteroids that pose known threats to the
planet Earth there are more than one
million known asteroids from kilometers
to meters in diameter most orbit between
Mars and Jupiter we have new systems
coming online again an example is an
American one called The Atlas system
which has a very wide field of view and
scans the sky rather quickly compared to
the old-fashioned surveys there are more
and more of uh you know professional and
amateur astronomers alike that use
bigger and bigger telescopes and they
just discover objects in addition to
these professional surveys asteroids are
rich targets for scientists it has long
been thought that they may carry complex
chemicals formed in the quiet darkness
of deep space and just this month
Japanese scientists found evidence for
that in the dust that was collected from
the asteroid ryugu and returned to Earth
it contained uracil a building block of
RNA one of the molecules essential for
life on Earth astronomers use these
near-misses by asteroids to improve
their abilities to spot the small rocks
that could one day pose a threat to our
planet Colin Baker Al Jazeera